Last question because I guess no discussion of presidential policy and the,
the possibility of someone like you running this countries.
How do you feel about international relations and the obvious issues of dealing
with other countries and what's going on with China and Russia and the
interference of our democracy and all the different various issues that we've
experienced over the last,
particularly over the last couple of years with Russia.
Yeah,
sure.
So about Russia and you and I were talking about this before we went on air.
When I'm president I will say,
look Russia,
I get it.
We have tampered with other people's elections for years and decades.
We America,
I've done that.
You've done it to us for the last number of years.
It is going to stop right now.
And if we have any credible evidence that you are tampering with our information
and our democracy,
we will take that as an act of hostility and aggression and we will retaliate in
some way that will make your life very,
very painful and inconvenient and the unit and the people of United States will
support me on this.
And so here is your drop dead date.
Like turn off the bots.
And if we find that your bots are still going after this date,
I will just bring the evidence of the American people and then we will act and
you will not like it one bit.
Now if,
if I,
I'm,
I'm thinking 80 90% of Americans would get behind that and it'd be like,
how are we just like looking at it being like,
what are we going to do?
What are we going to do?
And in this one,
I actually feel a little bit for the tech companies because it's very difficult
for the tech companies to,
uh,
to prevent
this almost impossible,
almost impossible.
It's impossible to identify.
And if you go back to Sam Harris's podcasts,
who we were discussing,
which is called the war of information,
that I think that's what's called information war or war of information for a
recent podcast when the last couple of weeks.
Um,
they detail how there's essentially just giant groups of people that work for
the Russian government that pretend to be people that are involved in black
lives matter or pretend to be people that are involved in Texas culture,
southern culture.
And they're just sowing seeds of argument and descent and they are laughing
their asses off and making funny memes.
Like some of their memes are really hilarious.
But to them this is the greatest Roi they've ever seen.
They didn't even like return on investment.
Okay.
You such an entrepreneur,
youtube,
right.
Man,
I don't have a man hangar.
I haven't normal freaking house.
So
uh,
like they invested not even that much money like,
but they've found like this underbelly like can just speaking slice into and so
they've spent best estimates,
like low tens of millions of dollars and it's caused us how much damage,
how much harm a real impact in town.
Like you know,
I mean you couldn't even put a dollar figure on it.
So you have to just say like,
look,
I get the tech companies are going to try but they're not going to be able to
pull it off.
So just like go on and to stay to like the world and hey this is to Russia.
But anyone else,
same thing.
Like if you tamper with our democracy,
we are going to come down on you like a ton of bricks and if we're not quite
sure,
we're still going to come down on you like a ton of bricks.
Like I don't need like 100% certainty on this.
I need like,
you know,
like a legal standard.
I need like 80,
85%.
Um,
and the American people would be like about time because you know the,
if we can't trust ourselves or each other or what we're seeing,
and this is before deep fakes and the rest of it starts hitting.
Like if you're actually going to believe in democracy,
then you have to start protecting our information as fast as possible.
And you also in mind,
mind have to start,
and this is a local issue,
but I'm in New Hampshire and Iowa talking about this stuff,
their local newspapers are all dying.
It's like thousands of local papers is winking out of existence because they
used to rely on classified ads.
There are no classified ads anymore.
It's all craigslist and so they all die.
And if you believe in democracy,
how the heck can anyone vote on anything if they have no idea what's going on?
So,
so there are a lot of interrelated issues and one thing I'm saying is like,
look,
we had a happy time where local newspapers were supported by classified ads.
It's over now,
but we're still a democracy.
You still need some information to vote.
So we need to try and find new ways for you to get quality information like
that.
Those thrown our hands up and being,
I guess the Russians are going to,
you know like just misinform us with bots and I guess all the local newspapers
are going to die.
Like you said,
like these are problems and we have to start solving them.
If you still believe that democracy is the best form of government,
and that's what we're going to carry forward with,
which you obviously have to believe,
like you have to go with that as your model.
And so it's all interrelated,
but we have to start thinking much,
much bigger about what we can get done because things are slipping away.
Things are trending in a terrible,
terrible direction.
Well,
Andrew,
good luck to you.
You're a good man.
I wish you well.
Thank you for being here.
I think your message is excellent and,
uh,
I hope you really make an impact.